she's the woman who claimed that Donald
Trump raped her a New York jury wasn't
with Eugene Carroll on that her Central
claim but it did find that he had
sexually abused her
very happy we're very happy said her
lawyer the client five million dollars
richer we have so much respect for you
McConnell is a former magazine advice
columnist she told this court she was
attacked by Donald Trump in the
mid-1990s following a chance encounter
outside this Manhattan department store
Eugene Carroll said she bumped into
Donald Trump as she was leaving the
store he recognized her as an advice
columnist he said he was buying a gift
for a female friend could she advise him
the two ended up in the lingerie section
of the Department Store Eugene Carroll
said he led her to a dressing room
Pinter against the wall and sexually
assaulted her a black and white
photograph that we've marked as DJ t23
Donald Trump claimed he'd never met his
accuser and that she wasn't his type
her lawyer said this photo from the 80s
contradicted both claims left of picture
is Donald Trump second left is egin
Carroll in a deposition to the court he
appeared to confuse her with his ex-wife
Marla Maples I don't even know who the
woman let's say I don't know who it's
Marla there's like Marvel's in this
photo that's Marla yeah that's that's my
wife which one woman are you pointing to
I know here
oh the person you just pointed to
was oh yeah
well it was for Eugene cattle said
confusing her with his ex-wife short she
was very much his time and when you're a
star they let you do it you can do
anything whatever you want and they
played the so-called Access Hollywood
tape in which Donald Trump boasts of
groping women hi it's true with stars
that they can grab women by the well
that's what it's if you look over the
last million years I guess that's been
largely too not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately
in the words of his accuser's lawyer
it's who Donald Trump is how he thinks
and what he does
eating Carroll hugged her legal team in
court as the jury verdicts were read out
Donald Trump gave his reaction on his
social media platform stating I have
absolutely no idea who this woman is the
verdict is a disgrace a continuation of
the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
Barbie was obviously very happy that
Donald Trump was not branded a rapist um
I didn't think there should be any
liability findings so we'll pursue it
we'll pursue that this isn't a criminal
case unlike the charges laid against
Donald Trump earlier this year over hush
Money Paid to a porn star this civil
case won't result in any prison sentence
but he is liable for financial loss and
then there is the price he will pay
politically ahead of a presidential
campaign what price the reputation as a
sex offender
James Matthews Sky News in New York